after 145 years lynching is now a
federal hate crime in the united states
the civil rights leaders gather here
today and most of all the family of
emmett till and ida b wells
thank you for never giving up never ever
giving up
19th century journalist and activist ida
b wells lobbied everyone she could to
ban lynching the practice of killing men
women and children most of them
african-american but some latino and
asian-american and then displaying their
corpses as a warning to racial
minorities they could be next and for
that her life was threatened
her printing press was destroyed and she
was exiled from the south
despite losing everything
she continued to speak out
in 1955 two white men beat shot and
drowned 14 year old emmett till because
he allegedly made a pass at one of their
wives carolyn bryant
till's mother mamy demanded the public
see his mutilated corpse igniting a new
anti-luncheon campaign
in state court an all-white jury let
till's killers go free and with no
anti-lynching law on the federal books
the federal court system could offer no
justice
67 years later congress finally acts
imposing a 30-year prison sentence on
those convicted of lynching
racial acts of terror
still occur in our nation
and when they do we must all have the
courage to name them
and hold the perpetrators to account
indeed emmett till's family is still
looking for justice they want the
justice department to prosecute carolyn
bryant before she dies and they're
worried time's running out
rosalyn jordan al jazeera washington